so good to see both of you season five
are you it's amazing that we're here and
the story goes in a whole different
direction you're moving back to take
care of your father booker goes to a new
school there's so much going on
what kind of journey will fans go
through watching this season
i think they're going to go through a
very nostalgic journey we are back in
san francisco in raven baxter's old home
he goes to raven baxter's old high
school there's some familiar faces some
antics that are just for me classic
that's a raven and it's exciting for us
so if it's exciting for us we know it's
going to be exciting for the audience
and isaac have you listened to the
cheetah girls
have i
have you my sister let me tell you
something
my sister um i didn't watch the last one
i only watched the first time
i appreciate you um but my sisters are
our big cheetah girls fans so yeah i've
seen i've seen my fair share
i love it and the fact that raven is
elena's back your nemesis
she's the principal and you guys have
such great chemistry good friends what
is it like to be back on set together
i missed her i really did ever since we
first met on the first sheet of girls
and she worked on that's a raven and
working with her and other projects we
always get along we're like sisters
beyond so this chuchi even in my phone
and being able to work with her and
sharing my friends from my childhood
with all of the new cast mates they're
like whoa this is crazy so it does show
that even though you're working on a
television show and it only goes for a
couple of years you can really create
important bonds that will last you a
lifetime adrian's so awesome
yeah she is pretty amazing and raven you
know i've been watching you since i was
a little girl and watching you come to
this point it seems like you're thriving
in your career you're the ep controlling
the narrative and i feel there's a sense
of you now i mean is this the best time
of your career and your life of you
oh my goodness putting that title of the
best time ever i don't know if i can do
that i like to live in the moment and
not judge because who knows what can
come later
but i'm very very proud of the work that
we're putting in i'm very very proud of
all the eps and disney channel and all
of our cast mates coming together
creating a show that we look at
as probably not the age bracket that
watches the show but we want to watch it
and that to me is a good show when you
want to sit down with your family of all
ages you want to sit down with you know
your toddlers your teens your tweens and
your grandparents and somebody laughs
that means that yeah we're in a good
place right now as a show as a cast
and isaac i mean does raven play like a
mom on set like is she completely doing
those tendencies as a mother
um
not mother
mother uh ravens raven's always been
like a a big sister to me more than him
well i caught raven's my big bro for a
fruit um and you know whenever there's
something that needs improving or
something i need help with she's always
going to be the first person i go to
even outside of our directors or
other executive producers i'm always um
always as big bro first he's fan
i love that you guys been together for
almost what 10 years working together
what have you learned about each other
that you just kind of like i didn't know
that that you were that amazing
that our brains are kind of similar
um even though we play psychics on
television i think with our time
together we can just look at each other
and know what's up and continue the
scene and things will be fine so we've
have some type of touch
that also doesn't work in the best not
at all not at all
because sometimes like i remember one
thing we had it was very intense and
raven's standing behind me and i'm
literally looking forward and i don't i
she doesn't she's not laughing she's not
doing anything the second i turn around
and we lock eyes we start laughing so
look at each other now look at each
other now let's see what happens
because i that is that was a great
moment that was a great one that was
great not in that saturday that's that
that was saturday no it wasn't oh you're
right
insane you guys are totally in sync
there totally
totally
congratulations to the both of you i
can't wait for everyone to see season
five it was absolutely amazing so thank
you so much to both of you thank you
thank you
you